you did post what looked to be a note
from lori
was that a note from her it was a note
from her she sent
uh me flowers and i believe a few other
people some flowers and
it was so nice to feel and have her
presence there at the show and yeah it
was really special
first of all it's good to see you again
oh you too
well let's talk hallmark because your
ninth movie
is coming out it's called if i only had
christmas
i know it's not your mom's recipe or
baked by emma but
hopefully it's a little taste of home
good i love this movie but i'm curious
for you as someone who has basically had
a publicist
since you were in your teens i want to
say
how was it to play a publicist
oh really good i i think that
that if i were an actress i'd probably
be a pretty good publicist
really that's so funny
after nine movies does it still feel
fulfilling and
challenging and exciting it really does
because i helped develop and create
these scripts with my producer
and so because i have done nine movies
it's not like they just hand me one and
say here here's what you're doing this
year so
i've executive produced the last 20
movies i've done for hallmark channel
but then the christmas scripts
particularly i mean i tag team with my
with my producer and so we wrote this
and developed this from the ground up
and so that's why it's so much fun and
this is an homage to the wizard of oz
which is my all-time favorite movie
and if there's so many fun things if you
love that movie you'll
notice the names they will take you back
to the wizard of oz whether it's names
in real life or character names and
and then the different traits of the
scarecrow the tin man the cowardly lion
the wicked witch of the west the wizard
and of course i play darcy from kansas
i absolutely adore this movie i hope
that everyone enjoys watching it
in this movie at one point your
character does
turn down this dream job
have you ever had to turn down a dream
job because of another booking because
of family or whatever reason
i have turned down jobs and the one that
stands up most to me is
that i had booked a television series
and and then when it got to actually
signing on the dotted line i
i thought i can't i wasn't ready to
leave my family
because my kids were still young and i
would have had to
travel to another state to work and so
i had to call them back up and say i
can't do this
because i i don't think the timing's
right and it was such a bummer
but you know you do what you have to do
and that was definitely the right
decision at the moment for me so i don't
regret it
what show was it forgetting the name of
it
it was like a police drama okay did it
make it
to air like is it still oh yeah
that's so funny oh my gosh would you
have played a cop
i even remember it's been a while i
don't remember like what
my character was i think i just once i
knew i couldn't do it it was like
and i never even watched the show but it
was awesome for several years
will you and your family on sunday when
this movie comes out will you guys
reunite together to watch it yes
everyone's too busy
funny because like my family does not
care about watching my hallmark movies
except natasha like
she's always up for it but my boys are
like not another hallmark movie
but it's my dad's birthday it's his 77th
birthday
on sunday so my mom and dad are going to
come over
so well i mean that's it because we're
you know very aware of the rules and all
of that that's happening but
since they're our immediate family
they're going to come over and we're
going to have a little
little birthday cake for my dad and
watch the movie because the christmas
movies are my dad's favorite
i love they're my mom's favorite so we
will be doing the same
even though i've already watched it my
mom was like can we all watch it
together on sunday and i was like
yes let's talk fuller house because it
ended
are there talks of a spin-off yet
no i wish that but no
i think even if there were talks which
i don't know of any this whole last year
has just
yeah blown every plan out of the water
so
who knows where any of that is anyway
but
you know i love fuller house i miss all
the people that i've worked with so
much and we're all still in touch of
course
but i miss going to work with them every
day and seeing their faces and laughing
and playing
and but i think about it now i'm like it
would be so different to even be doing
the show
right now because we couldn't be jumping
on each other and
hugging and touching the way that we
normally do we're such a close loving
family but it would
you know it would just be so very
different which makes me again
look back at what we've had the last
five years and to have finished the show
right before the pandemic hit i'm like
wow we just had the best of it
and i'm so grateful for everything
because it would be so very different
now absolutely
you did post emotional behind the scenes
what prompted
that well it was the one year
anniversary of the day we wrapped
our very last show so i started looking
through
photos and i just went to town yeah
there were so many good photos i'd never
shared before but they bring back the
best memories for me and there's nothing
like fuller house for me
and yeah i thought the fans would love
it you did post
what looked to be a note from lori was
that a note from her
yes it was a note from her she sent me
flowers and i believe a few other people
some flowers and
it was so nice to feel and have her
presence there at the show and
um yeah it was really special i have an
idea
i know you all think i'm corny and
overly sentimental yes
see now that fuller house has wrapped do
you foresee yourself ever doing another
series or do you like doing these
movies i know you also have the tea
garden
stuff but like an actual cable or like a
streaming
yeah i love the series world but
particularly
sitcom i absolutely love it so
yes yes yes i hope that i do another
sitcom
soon and i mean we're we're working on
it
and it's all about timing so in the
so not in the meantime because i
absolutely love all the hallmark movies
i do i mean it really is incredible but
it's a very different schedule
so sitcom you know i ended up directing
a few episodes of fuller house which was
so incredibly fulfilling and directing
uh multicam is something i want to do
more of but
of course with the pandemic plans just
changed you know
so right now that's not as much of an
opportunity just because there are very
few shows that are back to work
but that is like my wheelhouse i i love
multicam and i love sitcom people are so
invested in your family
and i read that you guys were approached
about a reality show a few years ago
it was worth a few years ago but yeah
now
would you ever revisit that do the kids
ever talk about wanting to do something
like that or is that completely off the
table
no i think that's off the table my
family doesn't want to do that my boys
and my husband
they are not into it or being in front
of the camera
natasha's forging her own path on her
own so and
honestly i think we're too boring to
have a reality show
you guys are not too boring i think
people really love your family
well thank you you talked about wanting
to do a sitcom
we know natasha is following in your
footsteps
is there a world where you guys ever
write and star in
a sitcom together like shit's creep that
would be amazing
i would love that but you know i'm
always
up for that and of course as her mom it
would be my dream to work with my
children
yeah and natasha's like i said she's
she's doing her own thing she really
wants to make her career
her own and i so respect that and it
doesn't mean that
in 10 years or 20 years
that we end up doing something like that
together
i would love it but but right now she's
very determined
to not piggyback me
in any way which i so respect